يعني هذه هي منطقه اخر الجلاء في حي الشيخ
رضوان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقدمت
بالامس في هذه المنطقه واحدثت دمارا
وحرائق واسعه في منازل المواطنين هذه
المنطقه كما تشاهدونها تم هدم النصب
التذكاري للصاروخ في هذه المنطقه ايضا
حرقت هؤلاء المنازل كما تشاهدون بقذائف
وحرقت ايضا سيارات المواطنين والسيارات
التجاريه عدا عن ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تواصل في هذه اللحظات منع اي
مواطن من الوصول الى هذا الشارع كونها
تتمركز في شارع الجلاء بالضبط عند صيدليه
ابن الهيثم حيث ان هذ ان هذا الشارع لا
يزال منطقه عسكريه مغلقه وهو شارع حيوي في
في منطقه الشيخ رضوان المواطنون هنا
يتكدسون في منطقه ابو اسكندر وينتظرون
انفراج للخروج الى منازلهم التي التي هي
في حي الشيخ رضوان في الاجزاء الغربيه من
شارع الجلاء يعني هذه اثار الدبابات
بالتحديد مقابل مخبز ابو اسكندر كما
تشاهدون
هذه اثار الدبابات حيث تقدمت هنا الدبابات
الاسرائيليه بالتحديد الدبابه تقدمت في
شارع الجلاء وصلت لمفترق لعند الصاروخ
ونزلت بالنيران تبعها الطخ الطخ الطخ الطخ
في الشوارع المربعات كيف الاوضاع كيف
الاوضاع الاضاع عننا كانت
صعب بسبب بسبب ان الدبابات كانت على راس
الشارع نيران كثيفه جدا جدا جدا حتى في
بنت من بنات ابني استشهدت وظلينا محاصرين
في البيت اربعه ايام والبنت مستجده في
البيت بعود الله ايش ايش ايش ميه حصرتك
الدبابات الاسرائليه وال حصارنا الا سبعه
ايام اليوم ال اليوم الثامن نطلع فيه لسه
كانت الدبابات و والله الدبابات صرح منا
على الجلاح وكانت تطلق ال والله الله يعلم
الطلقه والقبح طب هلقيت الميه بسرعه طنا
عمال بعب مع ميه فيش ميه ل لو في ميه كان
ماطلعنا من الظار هنا انسحبت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه قليلا من هذه المنطقه ومن من
المناطق المحيطه بها في حي الشيخ رضوان
الاهالي خرجوا فورا وقط يقطعون مسافات
الان للتزود بماء وهو ماء ماء مالح من من
بئر يخرج مباشره دون دون تحليه ويستخدمونه
للشرب ول حياتهم
اليوميه اقسم بالله العظيم انا قاعد بطعم
في ود فول اه مقشر قسما بات الله فول مقشر
بطعميه اقسم بالله العظيم فيش من وين نجيب
وين نروح يا عالم ايش تسوي وين نروح وين
حياتي يعني معاناه شديده جدا بع يعني من
شح المياه الاكل
الشرب النظافه ما فيش عننا نظافه ما فيش
عننا حتى الماوى يعني احنا شاردين نازحين
مش حنطلع من الارض ه ح نضلنا موجودين رغم
عن ان في الاحتلال ومعاونين والدول واقفه
مع الاحتلال حنظل على ارض فلسطين ولو بدنا
نموت